jackie for more on the continuing crisis
of the border we'll bring in former
acting heist director and fox news
contributor tom homan tom
we just heard that report from bill
millusion down there key word there at
the end who's coming in he says sri
lanka i want to ask you in the wake of
this
situation this crisis in afghanistan and
now the border do you see a tie to the
vulnerabilities of who's coming in at
our border
absolutely look i've been saying griff
for two years that this border when it's
when it's vulnerable it's just not
vulnerable to illegal immigration it's
vulnerable to public safety threats
because criminals come across it's
vulnerable public health threats because
they're releasing covert cases but i7
day one it's a national security issue
board patrols are arrested 17 nationals
from afghanistan this year and look if
you look at special interest only those
ontario watch lists they've already
arrested five there's three hundred
thousand got away no terrorists don't
want to get caught they're going to be a
part of that 300 000 that don't get
caught because the cartels tied the
border to the family units and that's
when that 300 000 go through and the
fentanyl goes through that's when the
bad guys go through so my concern is
this if they rested five
how many didn't they rest now the u.s
government's going to admit they've
arrested 15 known suspected terrorists
in the last decade that's what they're
going to admit to but intelligence
reports says there's closer to a hundred
they've already wrestled over 100 in
daring gap in panama uh hsi along with
panama special agents that were in route
to united states in the last five years
luckily we caught him in panama deport
them from there this is an extreme of
vulnerability on the southwest border
with 50 percent of the border patrol off
the line processing aliens we have never
been more vulnerable to terrorists enter
this country ever in my career so that
by the administration got it we had to
secure this border because this is an
extreme national security issue at this
time
so
let me
draw on that though because the outgoing
border patrol chief rodney scott in the
message to his farewell to the border
patrol agents said he views this not as
just a crisis at our border but in his
words a national security crisis as
aforementioned some coming across our
border in the southern border have hit
the terror watch list but now we have
the cbp in their words saying a quote
very small number of afghan evacuees
flagged for concern at bases around the
world we have cbp agents like yourself
that have the experience doing the
vetting do you see that threat highly
increase now because of the mass
evacuation in afghanistan
because cbp personnel don't know who
these people are look there's there's no
u.s embassy there there's no consulate
office there anymore they've been
evacuated so how are we verifying
passports are genuine how are we
verifying identity documents because the
afghan the afghan government is no
longer in charge it's the taliban
there's no way to verify the
authenticity of identity documents and
who these people really are i know for a
fact talking to law enforcement at
dulles air base
uh dallas uh uh
uh air
airport here in dc that a lot of these
afghans getting off the planes they have
zero identification not one piece of
paper on who they are so here's the
problem how do you how do you vet them
when you don't have any documents from
the african government or from the
american council i'll add something else
february march edition
i hate to catch up right there tom we've
got to go down to new orleans now or
join
the press conference there